so
modern solutions for men
you live together no legal marriage but
you have a ceremony
with your friends and family but you
don't sign the government contract you
could do marriage with a prenup
no prenup but date the girl for a
certain amount of time and then get
married so in order to offset how risky
marriages maybe you date her for a
longer period of time so that seems to
be what men are doing now they date the
girl for like two to five years and then
get married
um
you could be a bachelor forever spin
plates I don't know a ton about domestic
Partnerships but that seems to be an
option too
and you could just have a long-term
relationship and not live with her
modern solutions for women demand
marriage in the one to two years
demand marriage from men within one to
two years and cut ties if you don't get
it
date someone for two to five years in
hopes that they will give you marriage
live with someone with no marriage
stay in a long-term relationship with no
marriage sign a prenup and get married
so
um this is what I've come up with let me
know in the modern dating landscape men
what do you want to do moving forward
and women as well call in you have the
call-in Link in the chat
okay so the numbers on screen what do
they do they call it and then you can
put it on the line
okay so actually I don't have the chat
pulled up on my left but let me look
they have to turn oh turn notifications
on yeah make sure you turn my producer
saying to make sure you turn off your
notifications when you call in
but that's pretty much my question guys
because it's like on one hand we have
the women we don't want women to waste
their 20s on men that don't want them
right I mean
that's what they always say they always
say if a man knows he wants to marry you
to get admit that he's going to do it
within the first year that's what Kevin
Samuels would say
however on the other hand it's a bad
contract for men so it's kind of like
where do we go moving forward what do
you guys want to do moving forward so um
you have someone on the line
hello hello hi how are you
good how about yourself I'm good I'm
good
what do you think the solution is moving
forward to modern day dating
honestly I think it all has to do with
both women and men both growing in
virtue I don't think anyone is like
virtuous enough to be married nowadays
either men or women and I think the idea
of marriage has been so skewed now
thanks to how modern society is working
but going back to like how it used to be
I think is the only really way to
reinstitute marriage as a real thing
okay so you think
um
do you think that's probable moving
forward that people are going to go back
to traditionalism
I think there's like a pendulum swinging
in society so right now we're swinging
so far away from traditionalism that
eventually it's gonna have to swing back
because I think everyone's starting to
realize this is not working people are
unhappier than ever I think suicide
rates have been higher than ever before
and
I hope everyone wakes up soon and
realizes this isn't working we need to
go back
okay thank you appreciate you calling in
thank you bye bye so what do you guys
think return to traditionalism is that
the solution going forward I'm I just
turned 26.
um I don't have all the answers so let
me know what you guys think let me I
can't see the live chat for some reason
on my laptop I don't know why but let me
I'm trying to see the live chat blessing
I can't see it on my laptop
um hello
hey Pearl it's Doug MPA how's it going
Doug how are you
I'm fantastic this one's a a layup it is
the very first option you said for men
you have to live together
and um have everything like a marriage
but without a legal State contract I
think I thought it used to be a
generation or two of people that just
don't do legal marriages because that's
the only way it's going to change do you
think what do you think about single
motherhood do you think that would
encourage like more single mothers
well so the and the only Power men have
nowadays is to be able to walk away and
so getting married removes that power
away from you so you have to be able to
keep that power the only way to to do
that is to not get married so I don't
think it will decrease single motherhood
because
um women women are going to walk away
anyway like women walk away most of the
time it says yeah we'll walk away if
there's less
um you know if it isn't as bad if the
consequences aren't as bad to do so okay
okay
thank you for calling in Doug appreciate
you always good talking to you Pro have
a good one have a good one bye-bye also
guys I wanted to for the woman that said
Return to traditionalism this is just an
interesting stat that people get that
get married before the age of 24
actually 39 more likely to get divorced
so it seems like there's some downside
to getting married younger
um
I don't really have an opinion on it
it's just you know
what the numbers say there's a new one
okay hello
hello yeah so can I
yeah hi you're live on the air yeah
okay
one second one second make sure your
laptop's off so I can hear myself in
your background like I think you still
have it playing
oh there you go go ahead
what do you think the solution is to
Modern dating moving forward is marriage
outdated
okay so um thanks I was I was looking uh
to speak to pearly I really like your
show
foreign
yeah this is Pearl oh okay
um so what do you think the solution is
moving forward to Modern dating do you
think marriage is outdated
so I I think that the women today have
have changed so much so that there's no
going back and women are paid for living
marriages women are motive are
incentivized to live marriages and I've
seen my friends crying today at for
example today my colleague is crying
because his girlfriend just blessed he
told him sorry I don't love you anymore
I'm not in love with you but I I I love
somebody else so she just fell in love
with another colleague and he's crying
and crying so for me I I think that the
things are so [ __ ] up today that the
only solution for men just be a bachelor
and skin plate that's all that's all
it's bad but the the market is already
bad there's nothing we can do about it
women have changed so much that there's
just nothing I have seen my friends
crying their girlfriend leaving them for
absolutely no reason just because they
find another man
and for me
I mean I quit the dating Market because
I was destroyed by two women I my heart
was in pieces and I've seen my friends
that are still trying to date that have
been ruined
ah sorry I I think that this game over
marriage is an absolute social construct
and men should protect themselves either
you stay alone or you you spin to it
that's all thank you okay as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible